Over the past 50 years, boys
and men have lost ground at school
and work, and they're living shorter
lives.
They're less likely than women to
graduate from high school and
college or to earn advanced degrees.
They're dropping out of the labor
force in record numbers and account
for two thirds of so-called deaths
of despair stemming from suicide,
alcoholism and drug overdoses.
The Brookings Institution scholar
Richard V.
Reeves documents these and other
equally dark developments in
his new book of Boys and Men
Why the Modern Male is Struggling,
Why It Matters and What To Do About
It. He analyzes the structural
factors exacerbating these trends,
such as the changing nature of work
in a post-industrial economy
and suggests solutions that don't
come at the expense of women.
Reeves was our guest at the Reason
Speakeasy, a monthly unscripted
conversation in New York City with
outspoken defenders of free thinking
and heterodoxy in an era
of conformity and groupthink.
This is the Reason interview with
Nick Gillespie.
Today's guest is Richard V.
Reeves. He's a scholar
at the Brookings Institution
down in Washington, D.C.
and he's originally from England.
We're going to ask him about that.
I don't know.
It seems problematic, but his latest
book and he's written many
is of Boys and Men Why the Modern
Male is Struggling, Why It Matters
and What to do about it.
So please give a big hand to Richard
V. Reeves.
Richard, thanks for talking.
Let's start with what is
the elevator pitch
of this book.
That in many domains of life,
boys and men are now the ones
who are a disadvantage, including
some some aspects of education,
some aspects of employment and
in family life.
And that's especially true for
working class men and black boys
and men. And we've got to a point
now. Such has been the incredible
progress that we've made on gender
equality, on behalf of women and
girls, although there's still
further to go in many areas, that is
now not only possible to look
at gender inequalities that are
running the other way, but in my
view, necessary, and that failing
to do so will actually create all
kinds of political and cultural
problems.
So let's one of the things
that is amazing about the book
is the way that you document this.
Let's let's we're going to spend
some time going over the kind
of the extent of the issue or what
are the indicators that men
are not doing well.
And some of this is because they
are, you know, relative to women,
they're falling behind others.
It's just where they were 20, 50,
70 years ago.
They're falling behind.
So let's work through some of that.
What I
guess a good starting place is
when Title IX was passed in
the early seventies, which
conditioned federal funding
in educational institutions
that get federal dollars, they need
to have equal opportunities
for men and women.
The disparity of women
in college to men
was smaller than it is
now. Yes. Is that right?
Let's start with that and then run
through your list of leading
indicators of where men are not
doing so well.
Yeah.
So I really like how you made that
distinction, Nick, right at the
beginning between a relative
issue where there's an inequality
and an absolute issue where we're
actually seeing an absolute decline.
So if you look at education, for
example, you're quite right.
In 1972, when Title IX
was passed.
Men were 13 percentage
points more likely to get a college
degree, a four year college degree.
Title IX was passed within about 15
years the gap had closed, and
the most recent numbers show that
women are now 15 percentage points
more likely to get a four year
college degree than men are.
So the gender inequality
in higher education is actually
slightly wider today than it was in
1972.
It's just it's just flipped.
It's reversed and the other way.
And it's when you look
at the number of men going to
college versus women.
Bigger gap or what's what's going
on. Yeah.
And it's actually even bigger.
It's a bit bigger there. So college
campuses now, it's about 60, 60%
women, 40% men,
a little bit less true in private
colleges because private colleges
are allowed to discriminate on the
basis of sex.
So they're now discriminating in
favor of men to try and hold
themselves closer to 5050.
But across the board, it's now 6040.
And so even when men do go to
college, they're less likely to
complete college.
So there's both an enrollment gap.
It's roughly ten percentage point
enrollment gap enrolling
and then roughly a similar gap in on
time completion.
So men are less likely to go, but
they're also less likely to
complete. The result of that is that
15 point gap.
And at, you
know, in graduate school, whether
it's law degrees or medical degrees,
we're also seeing something similar,
right?
Yeah.
Much more recently, women now
account for the majority of
postgraduate degrees, including
PhDs.
That is a that's more recent masters
degrees, actually.
That was probably ten years ago,
BAs probably 20 years ago.
And so basically what we're seeing
is there's kind of this ripple
effect all the way through the
education system now.
So there there is no level of
education now where the gender gap
doesn't doesn't go in favor of women
and girls, whereas, of course, you
don't have to go back all that far
to discovered to find that it was
completely the other way around.